a writer in the New York Times accused
primarily been Shapiro
but also Molly Hemingway been Domenech
and me of pandering to our audiences so
playing against type as always on
today's show we will examine the various
and sundry ways in which the New York
Times is trash and historical
retrospective then Allie Stuckey and
Jacob arey joined the panel of
deplorable z-- to discuss Rex Tillerson
reported castration a congressional
candidate abducted by aliens
et not si and the latest navel-gazing
facebook meme in the wake of the
Weinstein scandal scores of women
posting me to
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this times peace may have been the great
highlight of my weekend it was called
the hollow bravery of ben shapiro and i
do not need to defend ben shapiro ben is
a big boy he can defend himself just
fine twitter excoriated this poor chick
at the new york times and really showed
her peace to be without evidence and
frivolous and i've never been one to
accuse the new york times of standards
but even below
they hurt paltry standards that they
once had perhaps just in my imagination
but the times article also talked about
me it linked to my episode last week or
two weeks ago on Christopher Columbus
Christopher Columbus was actually a
great man a link to that it disparaged
it I didn't explain why it disparaged it
it didn't actually make any criticism of
it it just said this was evidence of
pandering and frivolous journalism now I
scour audience likes the truth it likes
history it likes philosophy it likes
people taking history seriously and
philosophy seriously so if that's a
pandering then I suppose we're pandering
right we're pandering to people who want
an alternative to anti historical
ridiculous partisan narratives like we
see in the New York Times but it gave me
this great opportunity today to take a
brief walk down memory lane in all of
the ways that the New York Times is
absolute garbage and we'll begin with
this article the article begins and says
it's true that campuses tend to be
hostile places to conservatives like mr.
Shapiro charles murray and heather
mcdonald but the notion that they are
the cultural underdogs is bogus what mr.
Shapiro does on campus is shadowboxing
meant to pander to his conservative fans
whose values dominate mainstream
American culture if he wanted to be
genuinely brave he challenged some of
the wrongheaded ideas held by his
right-wing fans instead he uses his
megaphone on the website the daily wire
to reinforce what they already believe
now I I'm not sure of this but I think
Jane who wrote this article should
should have googled ben shapiro before
she before she read this piece Benja
barrow the leading anti-trump voice
during the election the
I use entire year was spent making
enemies out of conservatives because he
told them things I didn't want to hear
this is the guy that she holds up as an
example of someone who panders to the
right it's it's unbelievable it she goes
on I guess the more egregious claim been
has been you can think whatever you want
about him but the more egregious claim
is that conservatism is the dominant
culture in America when can you turn on
a television when can you go see a movie
when can you go look at a poster even on
the Internet even with censoring of
conservative videos by YouTube by
Facebook alleged censoring by Twitter
where can you look where conservatism
and conservative thoughts are not under
fire people being fired having to leave
their companies Brandon I kept Mozilla
forced to leave his company because he
has supported the definition of marriage
that everyone agreed on until the day
before yesterday there the culture is
oppressively left-wing people are being
fired from google for passing around
basically unobjectionable memos
questioning discriminatory policies
people are being suspended at
universities they're not being allowed
to speak you talk about the hollow
bravery of ben shapiro when he went to
berkeley it cost six hundred thousand
dollars to defend berkeley against a
five foot nine jewish guy who's
completely in the mainstream of
conservative culture and and is even so
nuanced about it that he can't fully
support Donald Trump he he calls it
balls and strikes and calls it likes he
sees it so that that's six hundred
thousand dollars to defend against that
guy it basically like the president
coming to town they're shutting down the
city but one conservative who has
mainstream ideas is so terrifying to the
left so unpopular so censored that it
costs that much money to bring him into
town the piece was without evidence I
don't think we need to go much further
than that
she was excoriated I'm I'm believe it or
not even shocked that The Times would
run it but then I I rethought about this
and I thought lest we think this is an
isolated incident let's cover a few more
just today the there was a headline in
the New York Times that said aiding
trans
gender case sessions defies his image on
civil rights
what image what your image the image
that you have painted of him he's
defying that image and he's defying that
image because it's a false image
it's a slanderous smearing narrative
that you're painting of him the whole
article was about what a terrible guy
sessions is and and and then it just
explains away all of his work the
article said this critics and supporters
agree that mr. sessions is more likely
to pursue civil rights matters in
individual cases rather than trying to
address larger systemic issues as the
Obama administration did he has promised
to punish any police conduct to violate
civil rights for example but is
skeptical of efforts to force Department
wide overhauls he supports prosecuting
those who commit violence against
transgender victims but opposes reading
the law in a way that broadly extends
discrimination protection for
transgender people this is not that
complicated for people who aren't in the
ideological bubble of the New York Times
Jeff Sessions is a federalist he doesn't
think we need a gigantic federal
government that's solving all of our
problems for us because as it tries to
solve those problems it will create many
more that we can't foresee so yes he's
prosecuting these cases but he doesn't
believe that we need these sweeping
powers created by unaccountable godless
bureaucracies that that are not
accountable to the American people this
example here is called the Fox
Butterfield effect we'll talk about this
later but it's an example specifically
in the New York Times where they look at
a situation and they see a paradox where
really there's a causal connection so
they say it doesn't make any sense that
Jeff Sessions would prosecute these
cases but he doesn't want huge sweeping
programs from the federal government of
course it makes perfect sense that he
understands the role of his department
and it comports perfectly well with his
view of politics and his view of the
government next this is from New York
Times Wall Street Journal editor
admonishes reporters over Trump coverage
now this is very scary they report quote
Jared Gerard Baker the editor in chief
of the Wall Street Journal has faced
unease and frustration in his new
room over the stewardship of the
newspapers coverage of President Trump
which some journalists there say has
lacked toughness and verb some
journalists there or some journalists at
the New York Times I'm not quite sure
the Baker Baker responded to these
emails there was an exchange that was
uncovered he said sorry
this is commentary dressed up as news
reporting so he's taking some of the
stories that were too hard on Trump he
said you're injecting your commentary
here we have to be straight news he
wanted I said could we please stick just
stick to reporting what he said rather
than packaging it in exegesis and
selective criticism so he's suggesting
that the news organization do with news
organizations are supposed to do the New
York Times is shocked by this the only
way they can view this is that it's soft
coverage it is in soft coverage it's
keeping the opinion separate from the
news reporting this used to be done or
at least attempted in the mainstream
media but for years it has not been
which is why you you see the nonsense
that comes out of the New York Times as
it does then there is a this is a letter
from the publisher to our readers from
the publisher and executive editor and
president Trump described this as an
apology for all for all the terrible
coverage that they did of him and
they're awful predictions about the
election none of which came true the
paper pushed back and said the New York
Times never apologized but the New York
Times public editor herself
Liz spade admits that they blew it to
the in in this letter they say after
such an erratic and unpredictable
election there are inevitable questions
did Donald Trump's sheer
unconventionality lead us and other news
outlets to underestimate his support
among American voters gee I wonder what
forces and strains in America drove this
divisive election and outcome the second
part the second sentence that's the part
yes you did misunderstand half of this
country you totally blew it you don't
know anything about them but then and
you acknowledge this you apologize for
this and then you immediately follow it
up and say what led to this awful
divisive terrible election it's only
divisive because you make it to vist if
any election by definition is divisive
half the people vote for one guy roughly
half vote for the other guy but
only you because of your horror at
Donald Trump in your total inability to
understand why anybody would oppose your
narrative would vote for your preferred
candidate only then is it divisive only
then is it awful and so even in their
apology of course they don't see it as
an apology because it's a false apology
they're saying we did something wrong
but really we didn't do anything wrong
it was it was on half of the country
that that made us do it
slap slap why did you make me do it I
hate it when you make me do this then
they do it they did an entire piece a
huge but you can get it right now called
Trump lies this is the serious
journalism democracy dies in darkness
all the news that's fit to print
Trump lies let's go through some of
those Trump lies I just picked out
random ones and every one that I picked
out turned out not to be alive was the
New York Times it was lying they said
quote this was a quote of Donald Trump's
you had millions of people that now
aren't insured anymore he's referring to
Obamacare The Times ads the real number
is less than 1 million according to the
Urban Institute sure I guess it's
according to the Urban Institute what
how about according to MSNBC how about
according to Van Jones the Urban
Institute is a left-wing think tank but
of course they can't disclose that in
their reporting and even the Washington
Post admits that after Obamacare was
passed 28 million people still lacked
health insurance and it's true that many
millions got health insurance because of
Obamacare what they leave out is that
they had previously lost their health
insurance so now they had their
insurance they lost their insurance they
got it again and but unfortunately now
the premiums increased the rate of
increase increased and they couldn't
choose their doctor the Barack Obama
said you if you want to keep your doctor
you can keep your doctor not the case so
what Trump said absolutely true the New
York Times said and not true at all
another one in the Trump law is section
it's gotten to a point where it is not
is from Trump it's gotten to a point
where it is not even being reported and
in many cases the very very dishonest
press doesn't want to report it he's
talking about terrorism in the New York
Times ads terrorism has been reported on
often in detail yeah ok sure I guess
they occasionally a story is run the
question is what is the volume of
stories being run where are the editors
placing these stories what are they're
focusing
our coverage on are they spending ten
hours on one thing on Russia which
you'll notice nobody is talking about
anymore because it was completely
frivolous or and then one hour on
terrorism or are they
prioritizing as the American people
would prioritize now here's an example
of this white supremacist Dylan roof
shot up that historically black church
in Charleston there was wall-to-wall
coverage of this for weeks we're still
hearing about it they got vicious white
supremacists
they covered the trial very closely it
was awful there's a national
conversation about Confederate monuments
and Confederate flags and guns and hate
speech and censor censor what-have-you
recently a Sudanese immigrant Emanuel
código Sampson shot up a historically
white church in Nashville the only
reason the shooting wasn't worse than it
ended up being is that the usher there
who the guy had pistol-whipped was able
to wrestle him to the ground caused the
shooter to shoot himself accidentally
and then pulled out his own gun because
he was carrying because they were in
Nashville and that's what people do in
Nashville of course the the coverage of
this was poultry barely existent
compared to the coverage of the other
one now both cases it appears were
racially motivated Dylan roof admitted
it and Sampson this this killer in
Nashville wrote a note that appears to
suggest it was revenge for Charleston
they are parallel stories but it
contradicts the New York Times narrative
and if a contradicts their narrative
they're just not going to give it too
much ink another example is the Orlando
nightclub shooting this was the near
Times headline Orlando gunmen attacks a
gay nightclub leaving 50 dead they don't
mention his name all of the Dylan roof
coverage mentioned his name but they
don't mention his name because his name
is Omar Mateen nowhere in that headline
does it mention that Mateen swore
allegiance to Isis that he's he was a
radicalized Muslim but all of the New
York Times coverage of Dylan roof that
uses his name because that name it is
it's clear from the context of that
story what was behind that shooting and
now it you know the Dylan roof brings us
to another lovely New York Times
headline quote sessions Trump Dylan roof
your Tuesday evening briefing
okay let's go through that Jeff Sessions
is the Attorney General United States
former esteemed senator for South
Carolina or from Alabama rather there's
a donald trump real estate magnate
reality TV star president united states
and a white supremacist killer named
Dylan roof why it's amazing at one of
those things seems not like the other
but the times they can't even hide it
sometimes there is so I think especially
in the age of Donald Trump
although they behaved this way during
George W Bush they get so riled up they
get so excited they can't help
themselves and and they humiliate
themselves in headlines such as that how
about this op-ed that the New York Times
allowed to run quote why we are on
hunger strike in Israel's prisons okay
it's a pro-palestinian piece about the
alleged occupation or the alleged
atrocities of Israel we've seen this a
lot it's my Marwan Barghouti now the
article originally stated Marwan
Barghouti is a Palestinian leader and
parliamentarian okay that seems
innocuous enough except the New York
Times public editor Liz Spade later
wrote a piece even she criticizing the
times for omitting that bar guti is a
convicted murderer who is serving five
consecutive life sentences for killing
innocent civilians
so Barbuda is Palestinian leader okay
check he's a parliamentarian check he's
a vicious murderer who's serving five
life sentences for killing innocent
civilians no no time centers we got to
leave that one out we can we're running
out of space we only have space for two
of your titles
let's leave in the completely innocuous
ones now try trash is not inequality at
the New York Times in 2004 reporter Fox
Butterfield published a headline that
would make him legendary the headline is
quote more inmates
despite drop in crime more is so more
people are going to prison despite the
drop in crime this is the butterfield
effect I think Wall Street Journal's
James Toronto named it that the
Butterfield effect is when someone makes
a statement that is ludicrous on its
face and but it reveals the speaker's
own biases right so they they express it
as though it's a paradox when really
there's a causal relationship between
them why is the crime rate dropping
because we're throwing all of the
criminals into prison that that would
make sense but to Fox Butterfield to the
New York Times they're living in an
ideological Fantasyland where in there
can't be a connection between
imprisonment and crime we all know how
unjust the prison system is anyway we
should probably open up all of the jails
anyway so there couldn't possibly be a
connection and that this this effect
this bias pervades their reporting who
can forget Lincoln Steffens the New York
Times reporter who returned from the
Soviet Union and declared I've seen the
future and it works in the Soviet Union
this was this was what Bill Buckley
reacted to when he launched National
Review he said a conservative is one who
stands with word history yelling stop he
was referring to that the future and it
works that future that future doesn't
work but he was shelling for the Soviet
Union of course this isn't the only
times the the New York Times is shield
for the Soviet Union Pulitzer
prize-winning New York Times reporter
Walter Durante famously wrote a series
of eleven articles on the Soviet Union
in 1931 I believe it was and he denied
the hollow dome where he denied denied
the man-made famine that killed between
seven and ten million people I believe
he still has his Pulitzer that this goes
pretty is almost a century back now and
I will I will talk more about that the
New York Times in my final thought what
we should do about it but now I think we
have to get away from fake news I've had
enough fake news for today my heart is
racing I need to get to some real news
so it's time to bring on our excellent
panel of deplorable z' we are going to
have on Allie Stuckey and we are going
to have on Jacob Barry but listen I want
you to be able to watch it I'm hoping I
know they've got a lot of great stuff to
say we have to talk about aliens illegal
aliens and Martians we have to talk
about the me to campaign we have to talk
about bob Corker saying Rex Tillerson is
castrated but you can't watch it unless
you go to the Daily wire calm right now
and subscribe it is just just ten bucks
a month a hundred dollars a year we want
to thank everybody who already has
subscribed it helps us keep the lights
on it keeps me in in Rachel Maddow
glasses polish
you'll get me you'll get the Andrew
Klavan show you'll get the Ben Shapiro
show biggest podcast on the right forget
about all that I know you're bored your
your eyes are glossing over well what
about this now have I got your attention
the leftist tears tumblr the single most
coveted item in the United States I
believe it is the perfect way to just
collect all of the Hollywood tears all
of the news tears I used to take this in
New York I'd bring it outside of the New
York Times building and then I could
take a shower and fill up my mug at the
same time I really like it it goes
really well with a little daily wire
punch over here you pour that in and
makes a delicious cocktail that's the
daily wire calm go over there right now
and we'll be right back
Ali Jacob thank you for being with us we
need to rush right into all of the
important news on the memes there is the
me to campaign which has been launched
on Facebook and Twitter Alyssa Milano
kicked this off she tweeted if all the
women who have been sexually harassed or
assaulted wrote me to is a status we
might give people a sense of the
magnitude of the problem so then you
might have noticed your Facebook feeds
have just got a lot of lefty people
tweeting me too me too me too
Allie there seems to be a pretty wide
gulf between sexual assault and sexual
harassment is this an important gesture
to show how widespread the problem of
sexual misconduct is or is it
disrespectful and absurd to conflate
rape with being winked at at work yeah
absolutely I also think that there's a
problem when sexual assault or the idea
of sexual assault and people being
sexually assaulted becomes a trend in
which people feel like they have to jump
on a bandwagon in order to be accepted
and I think that's kind of what we see
happening here if you haven't been
sexually assaulted or sexually harassed
in your thinking back trying to wrack
your brain oh maybe that employer that
one time did we get me or maybe he did
touch my shoulder weirdly and yet yes me
too
it absolutely minimizes the cases of
real assault and harassment that are
happening when people are simply adding
themselves to a trend to either look or
sound cool and it's a shame it is I saw
this on Facebook today a girl wrote you
know I wasn't sure if I'd write me too I
wasn't sure if I'd join into this but
then I just thought
even the fact that I couldn't tell I
wasn't certain you know if the guy
winking at me if that constituted that
made me realize that I am a part of it
and I have to write me too but of course
the opposite is true if you're not sure
then if that then you're not you to you
you explain it not you you'll you'll
know I mean it's an egregious egregious
crime
you'll know if it happens Jacob sexual
harassment can include unwanted sexual
advances sexual assault can be a guy at
a bar a drunk guy you know trying to
kiss you a little too much or being too
aggressive in his come-ons and there may
be indeed a spike in sexual assault on
campuses or wherever when there's a lot
of booze and no social mores and people
who who have a lot of hormones that are
flying through them but the same
feminists who insist on conflating
harassment and assault also seem to be
the ones who are supporting this hookup
culture this culture that makes sex
basically not a big deal so therefore if
sex isn't a big deal then why is sexual
assault so much worse than regular
assault can one coherently list sexual
harassment among the most widespread
social problems but also support the
hookup culture no I think it's and I
think it's completely hypocritical I
mean you people were saying oh when the
Harvey Weinstein story broke people are
saying oh look what's his name the
creator of Family Guy you know he joked
about it when he hosted the Academy
Awards and he was saying I was trying to
bring attention to it why didn't you
just say that he was a he was a sexual
harasser I mean if you really want to
bring attention to it so I think that
you know all these ladies are coming
forward and I think that it's important
that they do but these other people who
said well I knew about it but I just
didn't say anything I think that that is
them encouraging this culture and no you
can't have it both ways you can't say oh
I am four or Hoka culture but don't leak
at me are you crazy right absolutely
then as someone brought this up to me in
college we were debating is there a a
rape culture that's the term that
feminists use now she obviously isn't if
there's a rape culture in Pakistan
there's not real culture at on Yale
University's campus right but the the is
there a rape culture and that's a really
difficult question to answer if sex
doesn't matter if sex is just like any
other act it's like given someone a high
five if sex is without any moral
significance then why is sexual assault
so much worse than regular assault we
would all agree that sexual assault is
much worse
then punching somebody in the face or
what have you so but why is it much
worse obviously there is a moral weight
to it which flies in the face of the
hook-up culture that you know that
defines a generation okay enough about
sex we've had too much sex
what will stick to sexual organs because
a new report from bob Corker the
showboating senator bob Corker suggests
that the Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson has been castrated here as
Tillerson 'he's reaction i want to ask
about senator bob Corker who said
something about you and he was referring
he's a friend of yours he has tremendous
respect for you he speaks highly of you
all the time
he says that you're one of the best
things about the cabinet and he's
dismayed he thinks President Trump is
constantly undermining you this is a
Republican chairman of the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee he said the
president has quote castrated you before
the world stage that's his word not mine
what's your response to that well as I
indicated earlier Jake I think this is
an unconventional president he uses
unconditional communication tools he
uses unconditional techniques to
motivate change again I would say I am
fully committed to his objectives I
agree with his objectives I agree with
what he's trying to do how he wants to
use his own skills tactically to push
things toward change I'm there to help
him achieve those that's all you're a
cattle right you have a capital France
you don't want to say anything about the
Senate senator calling suggesting you've
been gelded before the world and it's
not anything that bothers you know I
checked I'm fully intact I did not
expect that answer you do have to love
Rex Tillerson I checked and I'm fully
intact I love the guy but Ally the
question remains has Tillerson been
castrated politically if not physically
I also love how Jake Tapper brought up
that he had the cattle ranch
I suspect way into that question for
today use is not his forte either but
definitely not calm I'm sorry go ahead
no not really well we have some people
saying okay this was Trump playing good
cop bad cop then you have people saying
absolutely not this wise Trump's way of
kind of I guess taking the credit for
being tough on North Korea
and emasculating Rex Tillerson and and
maybe that's true I kind of actually
lean into that camp rather than thinking
this was some big strategic heroic move
on Trump's part I think that he should
leave diplomacy up to Rex Tillerson
we've already seen that that's not
Trump's forte but Taylor s'en also knows
how much Trump values loyalty and that's
the game that he's playing with the
media right now and I have to say I
think he's doing a pretty good job of it
he pivoted very well with those
questions he's a pro he's really good
for a guy who spent his career as a
private businessman CEO of ExxonMobil
obviously you develop political skills
that way but he has been absolutely
agile completely adept in politics Jacob
should Tillerson have answered the
question about Trump calling Trump a
[ __ ] he in this interview he said you
know people say you called Trump a [ __ ]
do you deny at did you call Trump and
more on what happened the question seems
to me like the usual mainstream media
treatment of do you still beat your wife
but should he have answered it or should
he say I'm not going to dignify your
question with a response I think it
would have been better if he had denied
it but I honestly don't see his I'm not
gonna dignify that with a response I see
that as a denial it just didn't come on
strong enough but I think either way he
is saying no I did not I'm not going to
play this game with the mainstream media
because Trump's mistrust of the media
the well-deserved mistrust I think it
trickles down into his cabinets and so I
think Tillerson saying look I'm not
going there I think he's just saying I'm
not playing your game absolutely I
disagree I don't agree with that I think
that he was actually saying um or he
wasn't saying that he didn't say that I
think that he would have flat-out denied
it if he had called Trump and epi [ __ ]
I think in ironically enough he said you
know those are the games of Washington I
think that he was playing the game of
Washington which is good PR or want to
because PR spy said you know I'm not
gonna dignify that with a response
that's a really really good way of
saying oh my gosh
it is true the I'm really torn on this
because I I don't know if he called
Trump a [ __ ] or not I don't really care
I just certainly believe that in no
instances should people be dignifying
these little grade school questions from
the mainstream media with a response
even if I don't maybe he did call him a
[ __ ] but even if he didn't I think that
Tillerson should have the same answer I
am NOT going to play gossip you know
Jake Tapper you're supposed to be a
serious news reporter in mainstream
media you're supposed to be reporting
news I'm not going to mention which
little insults I've thrown at my boss
and colleague that's just its below the
dignity of the office of Secretary of
State but I don't know he's probably
weaseling out too who knows it might
have worked in both ways okay the most
important news story of the day a
congressional candidate claims to have
been abducted by aliens at age seven the
Miami area politician of course it was a
Florida politician vitina Rodriguez
Aguilera says aliens brought her onto
their spaceship they predicted that Isis
would develop and they telepathically
explained that God is a universal energy
not a person he's part of everything not
a person
gotta love Florida ally in the grand
scheme of things is this woman any
nuttier than your average member of
Congress most people in Congress that
she's just being honest about the fact
that she's completely mentally unstable
and she might not get anything done at
least she's telling you beforehand an
honesty is something that she has more
than the average Congress person and I
love her radical candor some of those
other psychopaths in Washington they're
able to hide their psychoses a little
bit better absolutely right and she I
think this was in Federalist 15 when
when Madison and Hamilton are explaining
that the purpose of the Congress is to
throw all of the crazy Psychopaths into
room so that they could fight each other
and not destroy the country I'm
paraphrasing of course so she seems
great we should endorse her I think
Jacob this woman claims that God is a
universal energy not a person which
seems to favor pantheism over a theistic
religion such as Christianity or Judaism
we hear this all the time people say
this a lot in popular culture they say
you know the universe is really good to
me
I'm sending you good vibes man the
universe is bringing it all together
right they talk about material things
instead of metaphysical things CS Lewis
claims that this sort of pantheism is
the natural state of man this is the
natural temptation of man in thinking
about his surroundings and that theistic
religion only comes from the ancient
Greeks and the ancient Jews basically
you realize there's something higher
is he right are all people naturally
pantheists both crazy congressional
candidates and regular old citizens
alike I would say so I think that if you
really get down to it everyone has had
some sort of cathartic metaphysical
experience but they don't want to admit
that there is a God out there because
then they have then they would have to
live by their by his standards and
that's why Iran said she was an atheist
originally later she came back and said
no I'm just smart that's why I'm atheist
right but I honestly think yeah people
want to believe in something bigger than
themselves even bigger than the tangible
universe right so I think yes we're
predisposed to this pantheism because it
gives us the reason to believe in
something without any consequences to
our actions that's true Ali looking
around the world at our situation today
is it more likely that we're being
telepathically controlled by aliens or
that there is Justin loving God yeah I
think Lewis also said if there's a
longing inside of us for something other
than this world are bigger than this
world there must be something actually
bigger than this world and I think that
that is a commonality that all of us
have innately that we have this longing
and exactly like Jacob said we want to
attach it to something but instead of
attaching it to something that might
have moral standard that's going to
demand an action we want to attach it to
this relative amorphous it's crazy being
ethereal being like the universe or
energy or vibes or something like that
something that's gonna make us feel good
but not actually have us do something I
think that we're going in the direction
of moral relativity which is why you're
seen but we're also going in the
direction of wanting to feel good and so
and so I think that we're going more
towards agnosticism than we are a theism
we want to believe that there is
something bigger that's going to send us
good vibes and good feelings not
something that's going to tell us what
to do and I think that's why we're
seeing this type of AB pantheistic
ethereal weird I don't even know if it's
increasing I think we've had it forever
but it's certainly becoming I guess more
prominent when members of Congress are
espousing future members of yeah and you
touched on it both of you touched on it
that we we're afraid of these moral
standards we're afraid of exacting moral
standards so then the thing that's
higher than us has to be physical it has
to be the aliens or it has to be the
universe because you can't derive an art
from an is you can't derive a moral
standard from a physical thing so we
have to move away from these
metaphysical gods into physical gods
whatever that may be otherwise we're
gonna have to like feel bad man and not
have all the good feels you know okay
panel so good to have you as always
Allie Stuckey conservative millennial
from the blaze and Jacob erryday Lee
Weyer zone now it is time I already have
my smart glasses on it's time for the
final thought
Andrew Klavan calls the New York Times a
former newspaper because he says they
used to be a decent paper until they
completely sold out as a mouthpiece for
the Democrat Party he makes a good point
the reporters as opposed to the editors
and opinion writers at the New York
Times are still generally excellent but
The Times has always had a strained
relationship with the truth and over the
past decade and a half
it has decayed into utter trash some
Republicans fall prey to their promise
of mainstream or left-wing validation
the classic example of this is John
McCain whom the New York Times would
praise when he criticized Republicans
only later to smear him when he ran
against one of their guys the promise
here is that the New York Times can
offer the patina of credibility a
desirable sheen for politicians artists
and cultural figures but the New York
Times is trash the only patina or sheen
it can offer is muck because it is
premise on a lie that the New York Times
offers fearless unbiased journalism when
in reality they are the most powerful
Democrat communications firm in the
country to cite a personal example that
gives me endless joy my best-selling
political tome reasons to vote for
Democrats a comprehensive guide outsold
the number one New York Times
best-selling book the week that it came
out by an order of magnitude but the New
York Times refused to name it on their
list unlike virtually every other news
source in the world they refused even to
acknowledge it only finally running an
op-ed that half mentioned my book in
order to suggest a handful of humorless
blank book titles that mocked
Republicans Ted Cruz's friends at work
that sort of thing the New York Times
has it's narrative they're sticking to
it and conservatives shouldn't waste one
moment seeking their favor or indulging
their nonsense oh what a fun show today
was really a spiritual experience
I am Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show tune in to Andrew clavin's
conversation tomorrow and and also turn
back here and we'll do our show all over
again
[Music]
you